[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 169 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
my name is Mark mantle and I am here and
delightfully joined by Gabby Ferrara hey
Gabby how are you doing today hello mark
how are you doing I'm very well very
very well game developer conference is
far behind me but you know next is
around the corner so everything is on
fire again don't panic it's fine
everything will be fine
so who are we talking to this week so
this week we are going to be talking to
Conan Gilbert product manager for stock
rocks we're gonna be talking about
container is a security sounds awesome
and then after that I get to ask you the
fun question of Gabby how do i migrated
my traditional data warehouse platform
to bigquery how do I do that but it
sounds really good and I'm sure this is
a problem that very many people have
I'll tell you later wonderful but before
we do all of that why don't we get stuck
into our cool things of the week Gabby
what have you got now you can automate
your reports on sheets using the data
connector for bigquery which means it
can get your stuff that's on the data
warehouse mark openness and that on the
sheet automatically to be updated with
Apps Script and other stuff there is a
post from Alicia in the new or
colleagues and you should check it out
how fantastic I didn't realize Alicia
wrote that that makes perfect sense of
course so there's a series of articles
that we're gonna go through on the
Google cloud blog giving you some
insight and some direction on various
aspects of the sessions that are
happening at Google cloud next so
there's one here called six standouts
serverless sessions
that's wonderful alliteration six
standouts several sessions at Google
cloud next 19 I'll link to it in the
show notes I want to highlight one that
I think is particularly great called
where should I run my code choosing from
five compute options that's gonna be run
by teammate Brian Dorsey I know a lot of
people tend to be like we have so many
things and it's so cool how do I choose
where I should be running my code I
think you'll find this is gonna be a
great session I should say but there's
also other stuff around cane native
running containers serve lists on Google
cloud is like a spotlight session also
took with stuff around serverless stuff
yeah thank you
and also at next this year we are
offering about 30 topics ranging from
building a better customer service and
to automated visual inspection for
manufacturing what do I mean by that
machine learning all the things take a
look at the show notes about nine
sessions you must see about machine
learning and next fantastic rounding
that out there's another article called
don't miss these must-see G suite
sessions at Google cloud next there's
about 17 of them in a list from small
and medium businesses or using Google
Angie Swede G suite migrations
accessibility features but I think my
favorite here is how to grow a
spreadsheet into an application I think
we've all been through experiences where
something started this is a spreadsheet
and ended up with becoming more and more
and more and more stuff but there's like
how do my forms its Apps Script an app
maker and so how you can iterate using
stuff use forms sometimes it's just a
great way of getting things done so I'd
be a client keen to check that out cool
probably worth mentioning though if
you're not going to be in San Francisco
for next next on air is available so
there'll be live streams of a variety of
sessions and all sorts of other good
content as well as extended viewing
parties that are happening around the
globe so make sure to check out the show
notes or just google next on air and
that'll take you to the right place so
that you can see what's going on even if
you aren't in a San Francisco on that
note let's talk to our gas corner
Gilbert awesome let's go do it so very
happy to have a Connick Gilbert here
product manager for stock rocks thank
you so much for joining us today how you
doing kana pretty well glad to be here
awesome well thank you so much for
coming as well Chris best a Crocs and
kubernetes security and container
security and all the security things
before we get stuck in there do you want
to tell us a little bit about yourself
in your background
sure so I'm a product manager on the
product team that stock rocks at a small
company that means dealing with
customers sort of triaging issues
understanding their needs developing new
features figuring out the roadmap and
working with engineering so it's really
a sort of all across the stack of
delivering a quality product a lot of
fun awesome at a high level do you want
to tell us about what stack rocks does
yeah so we're a crudite security company
and what we do is try to use the power
of containers and kubernetes to help
customers up their game and security we
build a product that goes across the
container lifecycle so bill
play run and helps them understand risk
understand where there might have be
exposed and detect threats and respond
to them in real-time what Google
platform products do you use for the
stack rocks platform yes so we have an
interesting deployment model we are a
security product and we want to run
wherever customers do so across Google
cloud platform other clouds on-premises
so we use a lot of GCP products inside
of our companies we run you know
kubernetes engine cluster actually two
of them I think on every commit into our
code base for testing and validation we
use the Google container registry some
of the container analysis products
internally for deployment and things
like that but then when we're deployed
we act as a kind of a self-contained
product we do integrate with the cloud
security command center which has
recently added kubernetes engine cluster
enumeration and findings tagging so
helping customers understand the risk
there but yeah mostly internal to our
company we're using GCP and really you
know use that to keep our debt velocity
up yes so actually kind of curious he
said like you're a kubernetes security
company what made you decide that
kubernetes was gonna be the platform
that you were gonna base basically your
entire business around yeah that's a
good question and it was definitely a
choice we made we started around four
years ago and around that time
containers were on the ascendancy but
kubernetes hadn't really won the game we
think really kubernetes is the platform
for portable robust repeatable app
management and security so we've seen
widespread adoption we've seen a lot of
the players in the container space
adding support for ori architecting
around kubernetes and we really think
that that's the place where we can focus
so we build deep integrations into
kubernetes we think that gives us a much
better position to help our customers do
a better job of security by really using
the power of kerbin at ease and not
going to at least common denominator of
just containers yeah
using kubernetes on the your day-to-day
and integrating to your product what
were the challenges that you faced so
I'll project a little bit back into the
past that my last company we started
using kubernetes in the early 2015 so
around the beta time for for Google
communities engine then called I think
just container engine and the
it's a bit of a learning curve now that
I've been in this space for four years
or so I like to think I've got enough to
curve but we find a lot of customers and
a lot of just folks in the space
community events that kind of thing
where the knowledge of kubernetes the
knowledge of containers hasn't really
penetrated the entire organization so
they've started with developments or
maybe the operations teams started using
it maybe it's in some stages of the
business but not in production but often
security is left behind so the security
team is often trying to catch up and
understand what the heck is this thing
what are the consequences how does it
deploy how do I monitor it those are
kind of the challenges we see across a
lot of organizations you said something
interesting as well you said just
talking about stack works generally it
sounds like it's both CI and CD so it
does continuous integration and
continuous deployment but there's an
integrated security aspect to whole of
that and I think of like security I'm
like oh yeah I just got my container and
then I'll be fine like whatever but it
sounds like you're being a bit more
holistic about it is that correct that's
a really good point so we call it a full
lifecycle product I mentioned earlier
maybe the build deploy run stages of the
container lifecycle so there are things
you want to apply in all those stages as
your app moves toward production but
also in the infrastructure underlying it
so when you think of making sort of a
holistic security program you really
have to make sure that your images are
clean make sure that they're minimal
there are a lot of things that can have
downstream effects in the build phase
and the deploy phase there are a ton of
controls that Kerber notis exposes a lot
of people don't use them because either
they don't have any incentives to do so
or they don't know about it or they find
it a little bit too complicated there's
another learning curve so once you know
how to use kubernetes and you know how
to get your app deployed maybe you don't
want to take another learning curve up
and learn network policies for instance
so there's things you can do in the
deploy phase and then in run time sort
of ongoing monitoring is important for
any kind of security threat detection or
response in addition there's that
underlying layer of the infrastructure
so you're securing your registry where
you're storing your container images
securing the cluster infrastructure
there are plenty of options for
deploying your cluster plenty of options
for managing it including on gke or just
on GCE so there are a lot of things you
can do and then we try to help people
understand all of us you mentioned
monitoring it didn't get a bit of my
attention what kind
monitoring stock rocks offer for their
customers for instance if someone tried
to access my 4306 for my sequel or you
know the iOS attack on what it is
I'll answer by discussing a little bit
about how people run containers and
micro services especially so if you had
the microservices design pattern into
the mix you're really operating your
application in a different way and
you're building in a different way so
typically people will start their
containers weather stuff their container
journey by learning some best practices
and packaging maybe existing apps into
containers but once they've gotten past
that initial stage they'll start
building their app to run well in a
container so they'll only be one process
running for the most part there won't be
sort of supervisors like starting new
processes every so often your app will
have one job for the most part so we
monitor a lot of those things and then
say well because it's a container there
are a lot of things you wouldn't expect
to normally happen if you're monitoring
a VM you'll often see people installing
packages there's some system and getting
inside to make sure that something is
deployed or operating correctly with
containers you often don't see that so
you can monitor the kind of signals that
might have been too noisy you know in
other infrastructures so you can monitor
those and then each report has more
meaning so what we do is in our product
specifically we monitor the container
activity including processes network
activity other things they take on a
different meaning in containers just
because of the way the apps are built
and deployed so now I'm kind of curious
like you've obviously gone deep on the
container space you have a security
background his containerization made
your life easier or harder from a
security point of view that's a good
question I'm in a different position
having gotten into the containers face a
little earlier than some others
certainly not the earliest I found out
about soccer
you know after it was 1.5 or so but I do
have that background and within the
company we've got people from ops and
security I think once people understand
the concepts of kubernetes they find
that it helps them to do their job
better so often any sort of reticences
is around unfamiliarity it's true that
there are applications that aren't well
suited to containers but a lot of
applications are and once you adopt the
container is a ssin strategy and
especially adopting kubernetes you can
really improve your visibility your
ability to really
and what a deployment is and to monitor
it some of those advantages are just
having all the metadata in one place so
I just spoke at besides San Francisco a
few weeks ago and just showed on the
screen an example actually simplified
deployment yeah mole so a deployment
specification for kubernetes then it's
got the exact reference to what image
will run so the exact file system and
code that's going to be there you can
have network security policies attached
right alongside you've got the privilege
level Linux capabilities the user that
it should run under the storage that
you're gonna access there's a ton of
stuff there's even annotations are sort
of an unsung hero if your operations
team is using annotations to understand
what they're deploying now you can see
them in security too so really you
having the kubernetes api it lets the
different teams even if they haven't
totally learned all the kubernetes
concepts it does sort of gather a lot of
information together and help people
speak the same language we talked about
the communities API being sort of that
the language that everyone can speak to
understand what's going on and
deployment containers in Ian's are
popular now and everybody wants to run
their stuff in kubernetes because it's
the cool kid on the block what questions
you ask your clients when they come to
you with an architecture and one of the
boy on communities what what do you ask
them it depends on really what your
application does some applications you
know will work perfectly fine in a
managed service some will work fine even
in like a surrealist context a cloud
function or something like that we find
that a lot of things that people would
run on VMs can sort of naturally move to
containers there even use cases where
you can use containers as a packaging
strategy but maybe not even
orchestration so some customers will end
up running containers on yemm's directly
those are kind of exceptions I think
most people can use containers and
kubernetes and they will drive benefit
from it it's more of the edge cases that
would require some extra care there's a
lot of people want to run everything
Corrine and is like for instance
databases stuff that is stateful do you
get that a lot and how do you explain to
them that maybe it's not a case for that
yeah so I think there's been an
interesting shift in the marketplace
recently so we used to have a lot of
people come and say oh you guys know
containers right
I need containers can you tell me what
they are or I need kubernetes
can you please tell me how to use it
sort of if you project back maybe eight
or ten years I've heard about Hadoop I
need Hadoop could you please tell me
what it is so we used to be in that
space a lot more now we're seeing a lot
more sophistication in the customer
space knowing sort of what's good and
what's not ops teams are coming up to
speed on containerization and on
communities but you're right that you
mentioned databases so stateful
applications it has been an evolving
story in the community I come from more
of a security background versus a office
background so I have less experience
directly managing you know databases and
stuff but it's it's certainly true that
people have figured out different ways
of using say stateful sets or even
resources outside the cluster to help
manage their stateful workloads that's
that's one example of something that
people might not always want to put in
into a crudities cluster thank you
I'm curious to know as well like from
your experience what you've been seeing
if there was like one thing that you
were like I just wish everyone would do
this either across containers or
kubernetes from a security perspective
what would that be or maybe two things
if you have more than one it's fine if
you look at the the things that
containers and communities will really
help you do one of the main things is
understand what's going on so there's a
lot of data in those deployments there's
a lot of data hiding in all the specs
that you've given kubernetes for how to
run your app and how to keep it running
and all that so if people would take a
look at those specs look at the options
they've got and just think about whether
the defaults work for them that would be
a huge difference so we see a lot of
people just running with default configs
and that's fine
same default in a lot of cases but you
can get a lot of benefit and you can
really leverage the value of having
split up your app into containers and
micro services if you take a look at a
couple of the options in the security
context and the pod templates that help
you reduce the privileges that your
container is running with or reduce the
risk that would happen if something were
to exploit an application vulnerability
there's one actually a really specific
one which is you can set any container
to have a read-only root filesystem so
there's a command injection in your
application say like the struts wonders
things like that or shell shock if the
file system is read-only a lot of things
that people will try to do just won't
work and there are ways you can do you
can have like a volume instruction in
your docker file or mount the directory
and kubernetes that let you have
specific paths be writable but the read
only Ruta fest it could be really
powerful to both enforce good
development practices and also you know
minimize the risk of adversaries
compromising your app and spreading
through the infrastructure have you
noticed a shift on compromised
applications when since you started with
the Security Initiative chakra did you
notice a difference between before and
after given accept but there are some
applications that are really vulnerable
usually I'm getting through malicious
HTML Javascript and sometimes gain
access to the server you don't notice
any shift on that we've done some
research the internet as well where we
do some hunting that research we you
know see what people start throwing at
containerized applications then we found
that really you know it makes sense they
don't know that it's a container so they
don't try to do anything different to
the applications people do try to attack
the new infrastructure components so
you've seen some problems with
communities dashboards being exposed on
the internet and then being used to run
code that's a new threats but it can be
managed and if your instance if you're
in Google communities engine you can
just use the workloads UI in the cloud
console instead of exposing a dashboard
directly so there are things you could
do to minimize the new threats the old
threats that have really changed our I
think command injection is one of the
biggest and just the ability to detect
when something like that happens is is
much greater because of the structure of
the container and that in the kubernetes
world you won't find a major difference
in things like storage or the cross site
scripting like you won't find a huge
difference just because it's in a
container if you still got the same
database you still got the same map just
the being in a container won't change
the game for those that sounds
reasonable do you see a shift though in
like where the rest's acuity
responsibility lies do you see
something's moving more to the cloud
providers and less to the users or vice
versa it's an interesting space because
the responsibilities even within an
organization have shifted so in the
previous world especially if you're not
in the cloud you may have a process
where security owns the Internet uplink
and they own the firewall box and if you
want to get your app exposed you have to
go to them you have to write a ticket
you know whatever you have to do they're
sort of in the process and one of the
big shifts with containerization is that
often developers and operations folks
are running the entire stack the network
is suffer to find the firewall software
defined in communities a lot of this
in places that don't have natural hook
points for security among teams there
has to be increased collaboration now
when you get to the cloud provider there
are different options for deploying
kubernetes and containers you have
managed services like google kubernetes
engine you can also run career at ease
using open-source tooling on top of
infrastructure as a service providers
like you see us after you do it on
premises the sort of shared
responsibilities changes depending on
which of those options you selected with
Google credit ease engine you can have
Google patched your master
infrastructure and keep that protected
while you're responsible more for your
applications if you're running a
self-managed then you will still have to
manage some infrastructure components
including the master including the
worker nodes security a little bit more
directly but in any case the cloud
providers never really going to know
what your workload is so it is something
that you have to do to make sure that
your images are in an ideal state or at
least a secure enough state that you
understand your risk posture that you
know what parts of your app you want to
pay more attention to send that you're
monitoring for threats the cloud
provider can't really know enough about
your application to effectively do that
now that sounds interesting
flip it around to like squishy people
things like from an organizational
perspective do you see that shift
happening in like how people organized
inside a company as well we do see some
changes in the way that teams are
managed and the way that people operate
together in this new world of cribben
ideas based infrastructure for one thing
people have to talk to each other there
have been times where been on site with
a customer maybe doing a proof of
concept and we've had a meeting together
with say the Security Operations Center
staff and the people running the
container deployment and they're meeting
they're introducing each other they're
shaking hands for the first time and
learning about their infrastructure
together usually this is when maybe the
container infrastructure is not as
mature it's a smaller deployment but the
people do have to work together to
understand this and if they've got an
existing tool that say monitors their
VMs maybe they do need to figure out a
new strategy whether that means
purchasing a new product operating a new
open source component or just
understanding where the infrastructure
is they do have to collaborate tighter
now in general there are trends around
this too so so just like DevOps there's
of sac ops and there are some companies
that have really adopted this it can be
difficult because asking people to be
good at one thing
is hard enough to be an expert in three
different disciplines can be even more
difficult but the people that really can
do that are extremely powerful and
sometimes we do see DevOps owning the
security of their application and that
can be a really powerful match because
they know the infrastructure they know
something about the application and they
understand this already posture
especially if they've got a product that
can help them understand it so beyond
full stack developer now we have who
stack them up sooo yeah there's like
full stack infrastructure to now and you
can debate where the lines are but if
you're going literally all the way down
some people are deploying you know
kernel monitoring they're understanding
a Linux kernel and they're debugging API
responses between back-end and front-end
and some distributed tracing like the
stack just keeps going what people get
wrong about containers and kubernetes in
general that you think they would get it
right like concepts and that kind of
stuff I think some people feel like
containers and communities will solve
all of their problems with their
application infrastructure and while
they're powerful tools you can't just
turn on kubernetes and then have all
your problems be solved it's sort of
like the go programming language is a
bit opinionated about how things ought
to work containers and kubernetes are a
little bit opinionated just in in what
they make easy so they make the
preferred answer a bit easier so it
could be really easy to run a stateless
app it can be really easy to get some
some services that are maybe auto
scaling or that are easily replicatable
it can be really easy to get that going
some of the workloads you've mentioned
earlier like stateful workloads it can
be a little harder you don't get that
necessarily for free overall you may get
a benefit from centralizing the
management and really learning how to
keep things going in communities for
those workloads but it isn't just a free
sort of we'll take our app we'll put it
in criminales and now we're good one of
the other things is around Security's so
the name of this technology containers
kind of has a two maybe three four or
five meetings depending on who you ask
it's been really great for the nautical
stock photo industry
so you've got docker with a ship or a
whale you know shipping containers a
bunch of other players in the space I
talked to if a rune for Missy oh and he
said he spent a long time with a Greek
dictionary trying to come up with a
Greek word related to ships and came up
with sto for sale so security also
doesn't come for free the containers are
still just processes they have some
isolation but you're sharing a kernel
and there is some more surface there
where it's it's not quite the same
threat model that people are used to
it's not necessarily true that VMs are
more secure they also use hypervisors
they also have problems it's important
to not just think of these as little VMs
it's not the same thing and that sounds
really good
so if someone's looking to improve their
understanding of security and containers
and kubernetes are there any particular
resources or places they should go to
learn more yeah so the community has
especially around new feature releases
for kubernetes has really stepped up to
try to explain these things so that
creative use documentation is pretty
good
there are also some blogs that you find
on I think just Keats about IO slash
blog or something I'm sure you all have
some posts I'm sure recently at a post
on CN CF they've been adding some guru
dailies content and some security
content yeah so I'll be recording a
webinar with the CN CF also about some
security topics that should be recorded
but I'm the podcast drops that people
can keep an eye out for it yeah and they
publish all the recordings as well it'll
be up if you miss it for specific
features there are good resources so
there are some recipes for network
policies that really explain how they
work if you're looking to get into
network policies you can do that but
you've got some features in our products
that help you generate you know
bootstrap your network policies as well
but you know the community does have a
lot of resources if you've got the time
to sort of get the concepts and and try
some examples and really learn the
concepts yourself that'll sounds really
cool
Connor if people want to learn more
about stack rocks and and that kind of
stuff where should they go you should
plug your stuff while we have you here
yeah so stack rocks com
this is the website we were very
imaginative with that domain we've got
so post up about your good ideas about
containers there's some talk videos as
well from I guess primarily me but also
some other folks at stack rocks will be
at all the community shows we'll be up
next in April
coming up at soccer kana I think as well
in April and May on the East Coast if
you're out there and you do financial
services
fs:i SEC conference the Red Hat summit
in Boston black hat Vegas in August and
the coop con in San Diego
whoo I've got some young kids so I'm not
sure I'll be it any or all of those but
I'll try to hit some as well awesome
well Connor thank you so much for
joining us today on the podcast glad to
be here thanks for having me
Thank You Connor thanks again Connor for
joining us on the podcast definitely had
a wonderful conversation about security
and containers but let's get stuck into
our question of the week how do I write
my traditional data warehouse platform
to bigquery maybe it's on Prem maybe
it's on another cloud I'm guessing I
have lots of stuff how do I do this so
every migration experience that we have
story.we involves three common steps
first you have your data migration then
your schema migration and then your
workload migration the data migration is
the data that's on your warehouse schema
migration it is the changes that you do
the outline of your database on the data
warehouse and the workload it's like how
you gonna keep feeding that to your data
warehouse Google Cloud has built and
launched data warehouse migration
servers to automate migrating data and
schema trickery and significantly reduce
the migration time because before you
had to do everything by hand and now we
have a team that you can consult see how
it works get credits and try it out to
see how it works awesome so you have now
automated - where should people go if
they want to sign up for that service so
on the show notes there is a link about
the blog post and explaining more
details of how everything were fantastic
and I can see here there's also a forum
where people can plug in their details
for qualifying customers so they can
take advantage of that as well yeah
wonderful
so Gaby before we finish up today where
are you going what are you doing what
can people find you not in a creepy way
just in a fun way
look you find me on Twitter but also on
Google call next be the week after this
comes out yeah I don't know I think it's
next week at buy Texas right after cloud
next then I'm doing a tour and Europe
going through a lot of places but I'm
not listening here because I don't want
to bore it anyway I'm sure they realize
to be here where you going
I will be joining you at cloud next as
well yeah call that two people we will
be doing live recordings at the GCP
podcast booth that will be on the show
floor so please come by and say hello
after that I will be presenting an East
Coast game conference talking about game
servers and Cap'n Eddie's all usual
stuff and then I'll also be presenting
at i/o as well so it'll be fun I'm so
jealous
it's gonna be good awesome well Gabby
thank you so much for joining me on this
week's episode thank you mark for having
me here and I see you are next
yeah see you are next and thank you all
for listening and we'll see you all next
week
[Music]